ce week-end les dirigeants tigréens ont
dénoncé des tirs à l'armé lourde contre
mais qu'elle est capitale du tigre est
prise d'assaut par l'armée fédérale le
gouvernement avait mis en garde les
civils avant de lancer l'offensive sur
la ville dont il a désormais pris le
contrôle le premier ministre habib ahmed
affirme qu'aucun civil n'a été tué par
les forces gouvernementales lors des
combats mais selon la croix rouge sur
place les hôpitaux de la ville serait
surchargé la communauté internationale
s'inquiète du sort de la population
civile dans la région
le secrétaire général de l'onu s'est
entretenu hier avec habib ahmed
le secrétaire général a exprimé sa
profonde inquiétude quant aux
conséquences du conflit éthiopien sur la
population civile en raison de la
propagation des discours de haine et d
rapport sur le profilage ethnique
même avant le début des récents combats
les habitants de mekele qui compte près
d'un demi million de personnes avaient
enduré des semaines de pénurie de
carburant d'argent et de produits de
première nécessité les infrastructures
civiles avaient également été endommagés
nos collègues et humanitaires ont reçu
des rapports faisant état de graves
pénuries de matériel médical à michele
et dans tout le tigre est depuis le
début du conflit dans la région plus de
45000 éthiopiens ont traversé la
frontière avec le soudan
venus du nord de l'ethiopie samuel theis
faille à marcher plusieurs jours pour
arriver au soudan il vit maintenant dans
le camp de réfugiés doom racault bas
l'un des huit que compte le pays akan
forme je viens des mra il ya beaucoup
d'armes lourdes qui ont été employés
dans la ville de tarbes
beaucoup de personnes sont mortes là bas
que ce soit des amis ou encore des
parents d'amis je ne sais même pas où se
trouve ma famille listes et cartes ou
confrontées à des difficultés
économiques majeures peine à faire face
à l'afflux massif de réfugiés
dimanche le haut commissariat des
nations unies pour les réfugiés
on a appelé à la communauté
internationale pour gérer la crise avec
à la clé une aide de 147 millions de
dollars
outre une énième crise politique c'est
une catastrophe humanitaire qui se
profile un peu plus chaque jour
dans la région